From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emily Crosby with Jennifer Lawson in her home in Washington, D.C. on December 11th, 2015.
We're here with the Civil Rights History Project, sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Thank you for doing an interview with us.
Thank you for asking me to do this. It's an honor.
Can you start by telling us where you were born and about your family?
Yes. I was born in Fairfield, Alabama. Fairfield is a suburb of Birmingham, Alabama.
One street is Fairfield, the next street is Birmingham. And it's on the western side of the city.
And I was born there in 1946, in June of 1946.
My father came from Central Alabama. He was the 14th of 15 children and that he then was born in 1899.
And he left his, he was born in what is now Bullock County, Alabama, Alabama near Union Springs, AL.
And he left that area when he was 15 years old and left the working on the farm there and moved to Birmingham.
Just really essentially ran away to find a job and find work in Birmingham.
You want to get away from the farm or was he just...
He wanted to get away from the farm, wanted to. He had a third-grade education. He was an incredibly curious man, really smart guy.
And he wanted to be able to learn more. And he came to Birmingham. He went to Birmingham.
And in Birmingham, he got a job first in the coal mines there. And after working in the coal mines, he then ended up driving the local motive through the coal mines.
And that he started saving his money and he bought an attractor.
And he took it apart and put it back together again so that he wouldn't know how to repair tractors.
He did the same with a car and then he started a little business that he called Lawson's Repair.
And that he then would essentially take everything apart, put it back together again.
So his business, because he repaired washing machines, refrigerators and the people that he served lived throughout the Birmingham area.
And through him, I ended up getting to travel to some of the places that were mining camps and company towns.
And to hear union leaders and when people were on strike in some of the company towns, it was quite fast.
There were these communities, powderly, and Bessemer, AL, brighten.
And these were these other places, little towns that were company towns for Tennessee coal and iron, which later became a subsidiary of US steel.
So he would take you with him when he was picking up or delivering?
Right, exactly.
What did he ever go around and repair stuff where it was?
He did indeed. He often would.
If a car had a breakdown that is quite possible, then he would then repair that car on site, rather than towing it or anything, he would repair it on site.
And he taught me and my brothers when we were relatively young.
He taught us how to do some basic repairs and so that I felt very comfortable with technology.
It was something where when I was really small, he insisted that I learn to rewire a motor and to create a motor.
So I really began to understand the principles of how a motor worked.
But it was boring to me to have to wind all of these coils of copper wire to actually create a motor from scratch.
But I learned those kinds of things and then we would allow us to keep the money if we then did small repair so that in the winter time when a car someone's battery didn't start or something, they needed a battery charge, those were things that we learned to do.
So it enhanced his business.
Did you spend any money?
Exactly.
I'm just sort of amazed at that ability that he could just learn how to do all of those things just by taking them apart.
It's kind of remarkable.
No, it was quite remarkable and that we have there's an article that we have been searching for my brothers and I have been searching for.
We had heard about it when we were children but we've never found it.
It was, and other people, so many people around us talked about it that we felt that it must exist somewhere.
And that was the, that during around World War One before I was born.
I mean World War Two, sorry, before I was born, that during the, because it was gas rationing, that it was very difficult.
He liked to travel too.
He really enjoyed seeing the world as much as he could and traveling, which meant that he would travel drive places.
He would drive from Birmingham to Toronto or from Birmingham to Los Angeles.
And he then, on one of these trips, in around 1945, he drove apparently from Birmingham to Canada.
And that the article that some people say was in Life magazine, but I've never found it, was the headline for it apparently was that Birmingham man goes to Canada on one gallon of gas.
And the reason that he was able to do the one gallon of gas is because he only need at the gas saline to start the car to ignite the fuel.
But then the rest of the journey, he'd really be burning these low-grade fuels like kerosene.
And that he had done some special converter to allow him in the car, with the car engine that allowed him to do this.
So he was, you know, an inventor in his own way too. And he was constantly, he was a tinkerer.
So we had, we owned our own home and we lived in Fairfield and that immediately behind there was a little small backyard.
But the majority of our backyard was taken up with his business. And in his business, his repair shop.
And there would, at any given moment, be, you know, two or three cars, therefore repair.
And he had a couple of men who worked with him to help him. And then he'd also have refrigerators or small appliances that he was working on to fans.
It's kind of amazing that he stayed in Birmingham. I think in that area with that kind of curiosity, you have a sense of why he, an interest in travel.
And was he connected to family or the community in a way?
And not, I don't think that that was necessarily what kept him there. But I think that we, it's not as though we were had the financial wherewithal to pick up and move somewhere.
I think that it was quite an achievement, I think, to live as comfortably as we were living where we did own our own home.
And living in a community where people, the economic range went from the doctor and the pharmacist who were, you know, a couple of blocks over, who had sort of much more magnificent homes.
We had a just a little modest, you know, bungalow style house. And then there were the kids who lived in the alley.
And so, and some of those when I was growing up when as they didn't even yet have plumbing indoor plumbing.
So, yeah, so real smart.
So, you had that kind of economic mixture and that with my father's business, there were any number of times where when they were, the minds were on a strike or when they were layoffs, that instead of collecting cash for work that he would do, that he would come home with all kinds of things.
It's like, here's a lady's watch or a radio or something, but it was real barter, whatever he could get for.
I guess if your customer face doesn't have money, you could go to the other side.
Right, right.
Did you ever think it was strange that he had you learning all of this along with your brothers that he didn't differentiate?
At first, I did, but then it was something where I enjoyed it. I thought I liked it. I liked the fact that he didn't differentiate.
I liked the fact that he respected us as thinkers, not just as his children. I mean, there were times when he definitely treated us as his children and that we were subject to the same kind of corporal punishment as all the kids in the neighborhood, which was just awful.
But there were other times when I feel that he respected us as thinkers. He would buy books, he'd buy his version of the encyclopedia.
And it was, and for him, a good evening at home was that after he had worked, that he would sit and read just at random.
From the encyclopedia, and it was something that was a kind of incuriosity that inspired me as well.
And for traveling, he'd talk about other places in the world, but as I said, that he'd talk about places that he wanted to go to, but that it was quite something for us in our community for us, the other people would marvel at the fact that we then would go to Mexico or go to Canada.
In fact, this sort of, in general, out of reach in your community?
Right, exactly, exactly.
What did you like about the travel?
Oh, just the fact of seeing the rest of the world, seeing, I mean, one part of it was that here we were in Birmingham, and in Fairfield, we had our own little protected community in some ways.
And of course, none of these places are actually truly protected, but we had a little parallel universe of the, so it was totally segregated during the time that I was growing up.
I mean, absolutely segregated.
And so that there were signs in downtown Fairfield that said, you know, laundromat, white only, gas station, white only, restaurants, all the businesses.
And the bus stopped in front of my house that then went to downtown Birmingham.
It was just, you know, you could get on the bus and for, you know, really cheap, go downtown Birmingham.
But it was that kind of segregated bus that had the movable barriers that were white on one side, colored on the other, and you were supposed to sit behind it.
And so, the kids would play with that by then getting on the bus, and usually in our neighborhood, when we get on it would be pretty empty.
So we'd get on and move the barrier up towards the bride.
So whites didn't have any space to sit by the time it moved around to their neighborhood on its journey.
Would you get in trouble?
Of course.
But not serious trouble.
Yeah, we were never threatened or anything.
I mean, the driver would, you know, sort of make us, you know, yell at us and tell us to move back.
Well, you know, I've seen the images and heard people talk about, like, in Montgomery in some of the testimony, the cases that came out related to the bus boycott, that the front of the bus reserved for whites would be empty.
Because whites didn't even ride the bus in as high as the number.
It's a movie and it seems like a perfectly reasonable thing to do.
And so we had this somewhat protected world, and that it was, we had our own doctors, pharmacists, dentists.
And so my father was a part of that world and that he was the repair person.
But we, and that there was people, people were organized by churches in part.
But we were a little bit different in that respect too, that while my father belonged to the largest Baptist church there, that he, and he was active there, he didn't require us to go.
He required that we should go to a church on Sundays, but that it didn't have to be his church.
So he encouraged this kind of free thinking. Now I haven't mentioned my mother.
My mother had been, before they married, she had been a school teacher.
And that she had attended college. And so she taught school.
And but after we were my brother, I have a brother who's two years older, and that after he was born, she stopped working and was a housewife.
And so she went from time to time to work as a substitute teacher at the school. But for the most part, she didn't work.
And she spent a lot of her time reading. So she read novels, she read.
Mostly I don't remember any real nonfiction books, but I do remember novels and magazines.
Do you have a sense of whether she missed that work? Being able to work, do you know?
I think she did. I think she, I think she, for me she is a rather tragic figure because I think that she was lonely in some ways and missed the world.
That she would have had had she been working.
And was that something, I don't know if you know this, within their relationship, but did your father want her to be home?
Or did she feel like she should be?
But I think that it was a sign of, for those times, I think that that was a sign of well-being.
I think that for the men of that world, that it was a sign that they were a good provider.
And it was a sign of how well they were doing that their wives didn't work.
And there were other women in the neighborhood who, you know, to make ends meet, they had little home businesses where they were the Avon lady or that they were the hairstylist.
But working out of their kitchen as a hairstylist, not out of a real shop or a salon and or a seamstress.
So there were all kinds, but my mother didn't work at all. She didn't work.
But I don't think it was something that really suited her that well.
And I think that she was really depressed because of that.
You don't think of it as being depressed when you're a child, but when you look back and you recognize that, oh, this is what's wrong with that picture.
You started to talk about what the travel meant to you, and then I think we got diverted.
Yes. So the travel for me, and I got diverted because I wanted you to understand that it really was this truly segregated world.
And that it was a world where you couldn't go to a decent library.
And I'll come back to that, you know, police. I'd like to come back to the library part. But that instead you, so it was so constricted.
And when we would travel, we would go to places like we'd come here to Washington, DC, or we would go to New York.
And my father then was always the one, the leader of these excursions.
And that we went, when we were children, we went to the Museum of Natural History, the Hayden Planetarium.
And those places in New York so much that I had grown to hate them.
It was like, oh, no, not in here.
I don't want to see the mummies. I don't want to see them.
Too educational.
But you appreciated it very much. And he would have this, he sort of was our tour guide.
Today is the Coney Island.
And he had, well, he had this narration. There were some things that, like, I keep trying to remember where it was.
There was some place where he had, where they had an exhibit that was these stones from some place like Peru or some,
but he wanted us to understand that people had built those without any mortar.
And that they had cut the stones so precisely that you couldn't slip a sheet of paper between them.
So was that kind of, that's pretty interesting.
Yeah, was that kind of narration that went with, you can't just go look at the dinosaurs.
So he had all of these details that of things that really were, you know, were interesting to him.
And that he expected that they should be of equal interest to us.
And that one day at the Smithsonian certainly, you know, at the Museum of Natural, one day was not enough.
You need multiple days to go.
Sounds like you shouldn't have been a teacher.
So he was in his own way, very much so, very much so.
And we used to joke and say that, boy, if he had a real education, he would have been really dangerous.
That sounds like it.
Because it was so, the travel for me was this exposure to this much, much broader world.
It was a place where coming to New York, going to New York, you didn't feel that, oh, whites must live here, blacks must live here.
We visited, we visited relatives who lived in integrated neighborhoods.
So it really makes that seem like an arbitrary...
Right, exactly.
Exactly.
You went to, you know, you got on the New York subway, you got on a bus in New York City.
And it's just people on a bus.
You went to a pizza place or you went to a restaurant or something.
And in Birmingham, the only restaurants you could go to were the sort of little soul food, black owned places.
And for the larger white restaurants, then they...
You couldn't go there to eat.
And that if you wanted their food, then they had the little window in the back.
Would you do that with anybody in your family?
There were times where if a new restaurant that was supposed to have something very tasty or something,
there were times when people would then go and try the food.
In Birmingham, you couldn't use the library to avoid integrating things that there was one point where they even took the seats out.
So it was...
But we were relegated to these segregated libraries that had, you know, sort of worn books and these tattered books.
So it was an in Fairfield, we then, the women in my community, had started their own library.
And so I and some of the other kids, we volunteer and help with the library.
But it was over, there was a pharmacist, our pharmacist, Dr. Palm, P-A-R-H-A-M.
He owned a building and that parms a pathocary.
And that his building was sort of the center of our little black world.
And that was the place where I had my first job where I got paid really, separate from my working for my father.
And that was working in Dr. Palm's store.
And I worked at the counter and he had ice cream and I sold ice cream to my kids, my friends.
But his wife, Mrs. Palm, then took one of the rooms above the drug store and made it a library.
Made it a community library.
And that she and several other women of the community then maintained that library.
Was it a popular place?
It was for us.
I don't know how many people used it, but for my generation it was an important place.
Yeah.
So you talked about this a little bit already, but can you talk about how you encountered race and understood it when you were young?
I think the first time I became really conscious of race was when I was very young, probably about five or so four or five.
And it was the directly across from my house.
My house was at the corner of a rather busy intersection.
And this is when I say busy, we're talking of relative terms here.
We're not talking DC.
No, we're talking relative terms.
It's that people actually did walk past because they used the sidewalks and walked past because there was a mailbox on the corner.
The bus stop was on that same corner and across the street from my house there was a store.
The store from the time that I can remember as a child, the store was owned by the Ragusa family.
And they were Italian Americans.
And that the grandparents lived there and were the ones who had first, you know, when I was really small they had started the store.
But then they had, there was this younger family.
I assume they are children.
The son and his wife and children worked in the store and they lived adjacent to the store.
And they lived, this was quite Italian American family living in the store.
And this was not uncommon.
You had then in these probably for every six blocks you had then one of these little Italian American grocers.
And that we then, I played with this girl, Teresa Ragusa, who lived across the street.
And she and I were like best friends because we get up in the morning and we go out and play.
And so since she was right across the street, we played together and the other kids, you know, she played with the other African American kids.
And they came that point when it was a time for us to go to elementary school.
And that that's when her relatives and my relatives, my, you know, black friends said you can't play together anymore.
And we sort of didn't get it. We didn't understand.
And you're getting it from both sides.
Right. Exactly. That you can't play together anymore.
You try to sneak in but?
Well, she would be on the other side.
We've been there talking to each other from our respective sides of the street.
Oh, it really was. You know, I'd be sort of saying, look, I got a new doll.
And then she would sort of say, oh, could you come over?
And I said, I can't. And she would say, oh, and I can't come over.
So it was this sort of separation like that.
So that was my first sort of consciousness of that, okay, it's a world where we are separated by race.
And then I'd hear the adults that you'd hear about.
It would be the times where you'd hear the adults talking about something really awful that had happened.
You know, a lynching or things that were, they were talking about.
Would they try to protect you from that or would they try to teach you about it?
They really didn't talk to us directly about it.
But you'd hear they wouldn't stop talking just because you were in the room or around.
They didn't keep it from you, but they weren't really thinking about it.
Right, exactly. Exactly.
Do you remember any of the things that they said you heard and talked about?
The worst thing, and I don't, this was, I was older when this happened.
I don't remember what year it occurred, but it was well documented.
It was a news article. There were several news articles about it.
Was of an African-American man who was kidnapped and castrated and in Birmingham.
And that the people, the white men who kidnapped him to sort of harm him even more.
They poured kerosene on the wound and unbeknownst to them that actually saved his life.
That caused the blood to clot.
And so did he, and he did not bleed to death, but instead that actually saved his life.
But that that was, became something that people talked about.
It's awful. Yeah. Yeah.
So that was, you knew that that was a part of this world as well.
And did you connect that to yourself? Like that something like that could happen to you or community?
Oh, you very definitely did. I mean, you know, it was that you knew that this was a world where you knew about.
I knew of the Ku Klux Klan, and I knew that the clan had marched somewhere.
I didn't know how close or how far it was from me, but I knew of the Ku Klux Klan.
I knew what they looked like, what an image of them looked like.
You know, I knew that there were all of these awful and threatening things that whites did to black people.
Were you aware of the bombs in Birmingham, or is it Birmingham?
It was, of course.
And by the time that that was really more intense, then I was getting towards high school already in high school.
And we would go back and forth. Birmingham, as I said, I mean, we lived just, you know, if Fairfield is a suburb, but it's truly just right there adjacent to Birmingham.
And about maybe six blocks from my house, there was a small historically black college, Miles College.
And the college was financially not doing terribly well, but it was a place where there were then college professors and others who were there at Miles.
But because of the state of disrepair, we considered it a big playground.
They're trying to save the college and you need to use the playground.
Because we could ride our bikes around and it was no traffic on the campus and things.
But it was that too became a place of community in the sense.
One of the, I, the one year, for example, and my mother and some of the other people in a neighborhood, I don't remember my father participating in this, but some of the other people in a neighborhood,
we went to Miles College to a screening of the film imitation of life.
That it had been banned, I think, or they couldn't play it at the segregated black theater downtown.
The Carver theater named after George Washington Carver, of course.
So we couldn't go to the Carver theater to see this film.
The Miles College was doing a screening of it.
So we went to this screening of imitation of life.
And this was one of the earlier versions of it.
There have been several versions of that, but this was one of the earlier versions of it.
I don't know if you're familiar with it, but it's a great melodrama of the woman who's passing for white.
So what did you think of that when you were young?
Oh, it became to me that was one of, I feel, one of the few times that we, as younger people, were having a discussion about race with our parents and with these multi-generational.
So this was a screening that included a discussion?
The screening didn't include a discussion, but we just, at home, and the city, hours was a society of front porches.
Yeah, and so there was lots of discussion.
Lots of discussion.
Yeah, people think about the idea of passing.
Oh, there were people who you had people in your family.
Everybody sort of knew someone or who it was, was passing and who had disappeared.
There were families of, we had some friends who, within their families, they were people who, they were very, very light skin.
And it was almost as though they were prohibited by their families from marrying anybody to Arkham.
Preserve the lightness or go towards even more lightness if possible.
And you'd hear that one person from the family was passing now.
And so they were, we talked to a firm neighbors family and, you know, they said quite a few families, members that left it, crossed over the government.
Exactly, yeah.
Birmingham?
How were you aware of that or looking impacted that house?
Well, we would, we would move back and forth readily.
I took music lessons in Birmingham.
I took, I studied violin and that I'd go on Saturdays for my music lessons.
At another point I studied piano and there was a black business street in downtown Birmingham.
And that we would go over to these activities and that I also had a relative who taught at a high school, the most prominent high school in Birmingham, A.H. Parker High School.
And that, through her, then she knew like, for example, Angela Davis's family or the, this attorney, author, Sherwers.
And that these were people who lived on this, the street of the sort of wealthier black families, center street.
And that they had lovely suburban style, ranch style houses, a raid along that street.
And the attorney, author, Sherwers was one whose house was regularly bombed.
And that, so that was, and that later with urban renewal, huh, that they then also built for when they started talking about the freeway, they destroyed that community specifically.
And it was one that whites were angry about because African Americans are encroaching or building nice homes.
It wasn't encroaching. This was a community that had been traditionally black.
But it was just the fact that these were people who had nice homes. And so if you can destroy any place, let's do that one.
So getting out of their place homes, school nights.
Yeah, it was really, where were your schools like that?
I went to Robinson Elementary School. And these were all segregated schools again in Fairfield.
And they were very poor in terms of classroom resources, equipment.
And teachers were not, you know, you had a mixture. You had some teachers who had very little training had gone to Alabama State or studied education.
And then you also had people who were absolutely brilliant. And people who would have in today's world probably gone on to Yale or Harvard or someplace and, you know, taught at a major university or at an Ivy League school.
And they were then segregated in that segregated world to these limited choices. And so each of these schools would generally have someone like that.
So you were exposed to very, very, very good and poor education all the same?
Exactly, exactly. And that there were people, you felt though that the people cared.
For example, at my elementary school, at both the elementary school and the high school, that the people who were the school lunchroom ladies, that they cared about the quality of their food because they lived right there in the neighborhood.
And they didn't want you going home and saying what they had prepared was inedible. Instead, you, you know, likely go home and say, oh my goodness, she made the best peach cobbler.
And they were using food that was, the food that was allocated to the school. And in some cases it was the government subsidy.
So as you know, one guy said, it says they could do remarkable things with those cans of government cheese.
Yeah, it's not a lot of varieties, not a lot of fresh toast.
Right, right, but they were, you know, did quite remarkable things, but the quality, they were people who they cared.
And so, and you had, they cared about us as kids too quite often.
So they had a real connection in the middle of a simple community with this school?
Right, right. And so with, there were some kids whose families, you know, one kid whose mother was an alcoholic and people, it was not just the teachers, but other people in the community would often, quite often, try to reach out to families like that to be really supportive and helpful too.
So that was, you know, you felt this sort of sense of community and of caring.
They high school, hand me down band uniforms, hand me down musical instruments, the books, you know, they were, we got the books after Fairfield High School had used them.
Fairfield High School was the white school. And then ours was Fairfield Industrial High School.
And this was, this gave me a sense of connection to all the way back to that world of Booker T. Washington, you know, because this was the argument that, oh, they need to have this industrial training and that everybody shouldn't go to college, but so you had a mixture of the vocational education as well as the college prep.
It wasn't called college prep, but you had that mixture in the school.
So that influence was still present. It wasn't just the name.
Right, right. Now it was Fairfield Industrial High School. And the, in the school, we were one of the saving graces of my life. And for many of us who lived there, was that we had this remarkable man,
Iman J. Oliver, E.J. Oliver, who then was the principal of the high school. And that one of the alumnus has, one of the alumns has written a book about him.
Yes. And that it was, and that we then, he was tough. He was really tough. But that he really sort of ran the school almost as if it was a private school.
Even though he was dealing with, you know, this mixture of kids who were the majority of whom were kids of miners and people who worked in the coal mines and the steel mills, and who lived in alleys with, you know, substandard housing with no plumbing.
That's the majority of the student body. And that you had, then this occasionally, you had this family that was a little wealthier and could go to, you know, London or Paris or something. And then you had the ones like my family.
So he had this real range and mixture, but that he put an emphasis on trying to make ladies and gentlemen out of all of us. And his rules and all of his homilies of, you know,
data struggle, dare to win. And he was, we of course,
resent it that kind of authority. But on the other hand, we respected it. And that later that we, after we had graduated from school,
that people appreciated him so much that we even had alumni chapters in different cities all around the country, even though the school no longer exist.
And that we still have an every other year on the even numbered years on the 4th of July weekend. We have a reunion.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, that seems like one of the valuable things of some schools in that era where everybody was expected to do that.
Right. Right.
Right. So that crown. Yeah.
Well, you described to me another time when we were talking about a family trip and you were going through Mississippi and your family was stopped.
Yes.
Very definitely that and this was on one of the trips west. You know, we would, as I mentioned, we would sometimes go to Los Angeles,
go to Los Angeles, Pasadena. And when we do that, we even looped down through Mexico and come back.
And so one time we were in Mississippi and was nighttime and we were stopped by the police.
And they came over and shown the policeman, shown his flashlight in my, you know, into the car and my father and said, oh boy, boy, where are you going?
And my father said, oh, he says, I just got these little cotton pickers in the back here pointing at us.
And he says, and I'm just looking for some work. Yeah. Just looking for some work for me.
And of course, we were resentful like crazy that he's calling us little cotton pickers and everything.
Then the, that completely disarmed the policeman, you know, and his thing was, oh well, you know, I think that if you go over there, I think they might be hiring somebody over.
Almost a bit early, makes feelings. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. He has to be subservient. Right. Right. And that if we, it bothered us to see him, I mean, we of course thought the world of our father and it bothered us to see him be subservient to people who, because he got a lot of white customers too.
And they would bring their cars and everything. And so, and that was the boy, you know, how soon you think you'll have this one fixed?
You think my car will be ready by Thursday, boy? Yeah. So it was. Yeah.
Did you ever see him challenge that kind of treatment? No. No. We never saw him challenge that never.
And that he, you know, he usually, and we never saw him either challenge it, but we also never saw him sort of being a sequest.
And anyway, it was that his answers were straightforward, but it wasn't as though he was being, you know, hat and hand up sequest either. And that he, he was active with the maisons and with other civic groups, these that they had a burial society.
So he was active with these groups of men and they would, they would read papers like they, we had a local Birmingham, Birmingham Mira, I think it was called.
We had a little local black newspaper. And the Pittsburgh Courier was another paper in the Chicago Defender.
We would get all of those black papers. And so they would talk about things that were happening. And he took great pride in the fact that he had, at one point, been a business partner with this guy, Arthur G. Gaston, Arthur G. Gaston, and Gaston became one of the first black millionaires.
And Gaston went on to, who was in Birmingham and sometimes my father, we would go over to the Gastons. And that it was quite wonderful because Mrs. Gaston was very gracious and would show us her latest buys from Paris or New York.
And that we, they would invite us to kids to swim in their swimming pool, too, which we liked.
I bet you did. Was that at the hotel or was that at their home?
This was at their home. Yeah, this was at their home.
That's something. So you said you dad would talk about what was in the papers?
So, but again, it was this kind of, it wasn't so much, they would talk about it. But it was more, again, this kind of matter of fact, talk of, you know, this has happened.
But it wasn't people shoot or there was no sign of action or thought of.
Yeah. Was your father or mother registered to vote?
Yes, they both were. And that my father was, he was also active with the Republican Party.
And that most of the people that I knew, they were all Republicans. And that the one of the reasons that they were Republicans was because the Democratic Party at that time, throughout Alabama, was connected to the Dixie Crats.
And it was the, you know, really connected to white citizens, councils, and some of the most racist groups.
And so they then were very much a part of the Republican Party. And that he went to, I want to think that he went one of his trips that we didn't go on.
I want to think that he may have gone to California to a Republican political convention at some point.
I'm trying to think. I know one of the conventions from 1960 was in California. I can't remember which it was.
I was in California, I was in Chicago that year. So what awareness did you have of the civil rights movement as it's growing stronger here, probably in middle school and high school?
And we didn't make the distinctions of calling it middle school. You went elementary through grade eight and then ninth grade and through 12 was high school.
And I, my first awareness of it was with the, my first real awareness was the Montgomery bus boycott.
So I would have been about nine, I guess, then.
And that the, with the bus boycott, there was, you know, I knew who rose apart was. I knew about the demonstrations and the bus, the boycotts.
And we had had some kind of boycotts and some activities in Birmingham. And the people in my world had been a part of that.
Did you know Reverend Schullsworth as a kid or ever go to meetings?
I did not know him and I knew of him. I knew who he was, but I did not.
How far away is Montgomery, your community?
Montgomery was at that time. It's about, I think about a maybe 120 miles or so. And this was pre-freeways.
And so when you had to go through some pretty god awful downstairs, this one town, Alibaster.
And that it was like a speed trap. And so you sort of eased your way slowly through Alibaster.
Because you, it had both the speed trap aspect of it, but you also worried then about being stopped by police.
So it was a longer journey than 120 miles needs to be.
So it doesn't feel as close as it was today?
No, no. But we did go to Montgomery. And we went to Montgomery because each year maybe once or twice each year, we would go down to my father's where he had all of those relatives in Bullock County, Alabama.
And there were a couple of times when we spent two weeks in the summer on the farm with our relatives down there, which was yet another world.
Did you enjoy the farm?
I did. I did very much so. And again, it was one where my father had introduced me to it in a way where of just sort of taking us out there.
And there we are. And he sort of says, you know, like this is our land. As far as you can see, and as far as you can walk, this is our land.
And that, you know, our folks own this land. And so he would then take us and show us things like there was one place where there's a spring that comes out from the ground.
And with this the Malsi spring water and the water was delicious, but it was this cold ice cold water that was coming from underground.
So, you know, those were marvelous things to us. And he wouldn't show us different plants and things. I remember him disliking it when he showed me a thistle plant and showed me how to, you know, he had me rub it on my hand.
And it's a experiential learn.
Yes, exactly. And it hurt. But he'd take us out and I learned to use a rifle.
You know, we are talking about people who hunt and and that in our house, we always had, you know, several guns.
And so, you know, mostly rifles and things. And so he would show us and take us and start with the tin cans and then watch out birds and squirrels.
You know, you know, yeah. Did you like shooting?
I did not really. I liked the tin cans. I liked, you know, for the sort of practice of it's like a game and a sport and you're trying to become accurate about it.
But to me, there was no joy in killing anything, you know, even, you know, a rote to me would not be fun to kill in that way. So I didn't like that. But I did enjoy the, you know, putting lining up the tin cans and shooting them.
Yeah. But then I just became fearful, more, more concerned about all of the awful things that could happen with guns. And because in our community back in Fairfield, there were the, a few years where it was popular for kids to get BB guns.
These little air rifles, pellet guns for Christmas gifts. And then there were the awful stories about people losing an eye to the pellet gun.
It seems like every time BB gun goes off, it's for someone's eye, you know, so it really, so with those stories, I don't know what those were, you know, suburban legends or what, but it was not of interest to me.
What about other elements of the Civil Rights Movement?
But I, the first was the bus boycott. And so knowing about the bus boycott, that was my first introduction. And then I want to think, but it's a hazy memory that there were some boycotts around stores, some idea of boycotts around stores because of treatment.
And the, it came more into focus though when I was in high school and that with the freedom rights.
And that was very definitely something that we were, you know, glued to radio, TV, watching news, looking at newspapers and, you know, getting word about what was happening, you know, particularly as the freedom writers came towards Birmingham in the freedom rights.
And Birmingham and the treatment that they get in where I think was Aniston and then Birmingham. And so that was all something that was very, very palpable.
Did you go into Birmingham when they were freedom writers, where I'm Birmingham?
Not in connection with them. We went into Birmingham almost, you know, we went to Birmingham probably every week, you know, every week we were.
And sometimes multiple times, like, as I mentioned, I would go over for my music lessons in the summer. I went swimming there. And since Fairfield had no public swimming pools, I went swimming in Birmingham.
And so there were all of these kinds of activities that we were constantly moving, that we had relatives that lived on, you know, one other part of Birmingham.
So we were just always moving back and forth through that whole geography was my world. So it wasn't. I didn't think of it as separate.
Yeah. And it was an easy kind of movement back and forth. I could bike to the swimming pools. I could bike to some of these places.
Yeah. It must have, the freedom rights going through Birmingham must have made that seem very real.
Oh, very much so. Right. No, very much so. So the freedom rights were very definitely a big deal. And then also when Martin Luther King and the demonstrations in Martin Luther King in Birmingham, jail.
And that the call then for students to participate. That was the first time that we then and I was in high school and that Professor Oliver, our principal, forbade us to participate and to leave campus.
In fact, he sort of, you know, locked the school doors because he didn't want us participating in the demonstrations. And that that was just the wrong thing to do with a group of.
Yeah, because then of course we then left school. We at a guest, his orders and went downtown Birmingham to participate.
And some of the kids were some of my classmates were arrested and this is now the Kelly Ingram Park demonstrations and things and some people were arrested. Some were, you know, hit by the with the firehoses and everything. I was not.
I wasn't down. I wasn't in that area when those events took place. But I had left school and was participating in these demonstrations.
Were you the arresting? No, not at that time. Yeah. What did your parents think?
That by then my mother had passed away. My mother had died and my father though had at first he then was upset that we had disobeyed because I think that the principal called our parents.
And you know that so there was for about a cut we were suspended I think from school and so for a couple of weeks we were, you know, what we we were being being castigated for what we had done.
And it wasn't that we were being castigated for participating in the civil rights activities. It was for disobeying our elders.
Is that coming from your father or the principal? The principal, the principal but with parents, you know, piling on and then it became sort of the it turned at some point.
I can't there was a point at which it changed where then we were being hailed as heroes.
I think it's one of the victory came.
Well, this was right during that time period it became okay that we had done this so by the time I graduated from high school in May of 63.
It was okay. It wasn't this wasn't mentioned because this still was I think the principal was still smarting from the fact that we had disobeyed him.
But that it wasn't you know now it was not as though this was an awful thing that we had done.
And so I think that it gave doing so gave me greater confidence. You know, I think that we think I and my classmates we certainly felt that we did the right thing.
And that we and that with my father we went to a couple of mass meetings but I don't remember I don't remember precisely what the meetings were about.
But I I know that they were connected still to the campaign that King and others SCLC had in reference to Birmingham.
Do you remember what it was like to be in the mass meetings? How you felt?
I felt it was a very positive feeling and the only other time that I had experienced that was when we had gone to that screening that I mentioned at Miles College when I was younger.
That and it was the because it was the people of my community that we were a community.
But we were a community around an issue or a topic not a community around a funeral or because that's generally when we would gather in a church or in any place where we're sitting down in a large group you know over 50s.
And to my sense this was like probably like a hundred people or more and you know crowded church churches and that these were the only times when we were there for a serious conversation about a topic and not for preacher harranging us about you know fire and brimstone and right exactly.
I don't not at that point later but I don't remember hearing him speak when I was in high school in Birmingham but you know.
When you were in high school did you have any sense that you would ultimately immerse yourself in the movement and become a full time?
Not at all very definitely not not at all.
At that point I really thought that I would likely I thought that I would have a career in medicine and that I was focused more on the sciences and that I thought that I would probably live in New York and work in New York.
You mentioned to me another time that you had internships in the summer.
Right exactly.
One of the influences.
Right.
Can you talk about that?
And that was both and interesting because that was one of the conflicts that I had with my civil rights work.
It was these you know having at that age to make some really hard choices and tough decisions and the summer of 63 I was in New York.
So I did not participate.
I followed the March on Washington in the newspapers and on television but I was in New York working at Hayden Planetarium Memorial Center because I had this internship there.
How did you get that?
Yes I know exactly how I got that.
My father, my father as I mentioned my father was born in 1899 and so my father was an older father in one sense and he had had a previous family.
He had been married before and his first wife had died and in his first marriage he had two daughters.
He had another child who didn't survive him, a young guy who died as a young boy.
But he had his daughters and so I had two sisters and that my sisters lived in New York City and my sisters worked at Hayden Planetarium.
They were lab technicians. My father had seen to be in some ways like the proverbial Jewish mother where he wanted a doctor in the family.
And so he had tried that with them and had not succeeded but he had gotten to the point that they had become lab technologists.
So they were lab technicians and they worked at Hayden Planetarium and they worked in cancer research and so when they then learned that there was this internship program they invited me to apply for it and I was accepted and so they said that I could stay with one of them.
And while I went through that it just happened to be the year two that they were both pregnant.
Interesting Tyree.
And so I ended up also having newborn nephews and...
Wow, that's quite an experience.
Yes. It gave you a sense of what you wanted in your immediate future.
Well, I was most impressed. I loved working in New York City.
The children were not... The children were interesting but I had been around babies in my community, sadly even at that point teenage girls would have their own kids and everything.
And I knew that was not something that I wanted.
Not right now.
But what I did really loved, I loved living in New York.
And so I stayed in Queens with my sister and would take the train in to Manhattan each day. It worked at Hayden Planetarium and through the people at Hayden Planetarium I met...
There was one woman who worked there as well. She was a nurse and she had...
She was originally I think from Sweden. But she became a friend and invited me sometimes to stay over in the city with her and her roommates.
And one of her roommates was a flight attendant and another worked at the UN.
And they would invite me to parties and things.
So this was all quite heavy stuff for... I mean I think I was 16 or 17 years old at the time.
So this was absolutely wonderful. And we'd go to plays and I saw the flying Dutchman. I saw several other really wonderful plays and saw experimental theatre as well as my sister leaned towards the Broadway musicals.
My older sister did and so I'd go to those with her. But in addition to that, the friends that I met liked things that were a lot more intellectually challenging and much more cosmopolitan.
So it was just wonderful.
It sounds like you had a lot more opportunities to see the outside world in your average Southern kid.
Exactly. So I was really enjoying that experience but I also felt that I should be at the Marge on Washington, I should.
And I would talk with the doctors there about this. We've been... I made some really nice friendships for that time and we talk about this.
Are they interested, supported?
They were supportive. They were... all of them were absolutely supportive. And they even sort of said that if I was interested, that one was at that point a dean at Cornell and said that if I was interested, he would help me get into Cornell and then I could then go to Cornell's medical school.
So they were very, very supportive. So I had this wonderful array of friends and there but that I also then felt by virtue of what I was reading about and what was happening in the movement that I should be in terms of the Marge on Washington, that that's where I should be as well.
Did you try to figure out how to get there? Did you get that far?
No, no because I knew it was...
The last call. Yeah. Were you interested in being a doctor? Did that appeal to you?
I was. I was very... at that point I was interested. I felt that I was good at science and particularly at biology and that I thought that I could be a very competent doctor, a good doctor.
But it was also something where the experience that year at Hayden Planetarium that I began to realize too though that I didn't want to work with people who were dying.
You know, it was that I didn't work directly with patients instead I was doing this lab work and doing the math. This was pre-computers.
So we do these lab tests and you do the readings and then I spend the last half of the afternoon doing all of these computations and you were doing those with one of these big calculators and a slight rule.
And I loved my slight rule and I was so thrilled that I had mastered the slight rule.
But you know, so you do all of these computations but then there was...
So and then you'd give the results to the doctors and that's where they would do...
You were doing blood and you're an analysis and they would then make decisions about treatment.
And then there would be this times when you would say, oh, you don't have to do this person anymore. You can just discard that and that meant that the person had died.
And so that was something that I felt was like, I don't know, I'm not so sure about being a doctor.
Especially not when working in cancer treatment.
And then the next year I went back to Sloan, the summer of 1964. They invited me back. I went back to the summer of 1964.
And this time I thought, well, maybe I should focus more on the research side.
And this was now... they were doing the experiments with the lab animals, you know, with the dogs and you didn't check the die into the dogs and the rats and tracing to the rats.
Tracing tumors and things. And so that was also not exactly something that...
It gave you a real sense of how challenging and how difficult this work was and how we were so clueless about cancer.
And there was one doctor who I worked with, I don't remember his name.
And that he was so highly respected because he had done some kind of isolation of something that was considered quite important.
And I remember thinking, oh, this is so wonderful. I'm getting to work with him. And one day I just sort of casually asked him, so how long have you been doing this?
And he said, 20 years. And for me, at my age, to think that 20 years and at all that he has done is to isolate this one little thing that in terms of a cure or treatment of cancer means very little.
Just, you know, seemed as though you were trying to, you know, sort of eat the moon or something.
So those hands on experiences were very educational.
They were very educational, very, very good and very productive for me.
And but that was the point at which then I was, and that was the summer of 64 where again now I felt that I really should be in the south.
And here I was reading about Goodman, you know, Cheney and Schwerner.
Yeah, I was reading about Freedom Summer, you know, in the pages of The New York Times.
Freedom College by this time?
I was. I was at Tuskegee. I was at Tuskegee.
So would this have been the summer after your freshman year, probably?
Right. And at Tuskegee, I had the first year that when I, right after I arrived there, I became, I started meeting students.
There was, you know, you, you end up with the usual group where they are trying to get you to become part of a sorority.
And, and I realized I had absolutely no interest in that whatsoever.
And there was a group of students who were talking about some demonstrations about desegregating down the little downtown area of Tuskegee.
And so that appealed to me much, much more.
That was something that I was far more interested in.
So I'd then attended some of the student meetings around that.
And then I also met this woman, Almena Lomax, who's Almena Lomax.
The later became the head of Fulton County.
And now I think he's with the United Negro College Fund.
His mother, at that time, ran a little news, had a newspaper in Tuskegee.
And she and this other man, Dr. Gomillion v. Lightfoot, and Gomillion v. Lightfoot was doing interested in voter rights.
And for some reason, I don't know why I went to meet with him.
I was really curious about what he was doing.
But I became very interested.
His focus was Jerry Mandory, and about how they had taken Macon County and done all of his work.
The whites had just broken the county up in ways so that you would never be able, blacks would never be able to like have a majority and get a vote.
And for some reason that intrigued me and was of real interest to me.
And it wasn't, it didn't have anything to do with my schoolwork.
And so I became it.
But I went over and met with him.
And through a combination of those meetings and meeting other people,
I became much more interested in working on some of the civil rights issues there at Tuskegee.
I know that he was involved in a Supreme Court case related to voting and making a...
Do you remember what that had been heard before after you met him?
I don't know.
Yeah, that's what I think.
He had been the work that he was doing was something that he had been doing for quite some time.
To financially, at that point, at one point, I don't remember whether it was that.
I needed, because I was able to go to college only because I had a full scholarship.
And my mother had sort of said, you know, you want to go to college?
That's great.
Go ahead.
You might go right away.
Did your older brother go?
My older brother did.
My older brother went to Tennessee State for a while and then for a year.
And then he transferred to Tuskegee.
So he followed you?
He did indeed.
So we were both at Tuskegee yet.
And when I think he actually ended up at Tuskegee before I did, though.
Yeah, I think he didn't follow me.
I think he was at Tuskegee before me.
And when I was at Tuskegee, that I then really was not getting...
Maybe I'd get $10 every quarter from my day at or something.
But...
Very generous, a lot.
Not much at all.
So that I needed to work.
And at one point, the job that I had, I had gotten myself a job working in the hospital
based on my experience with Hayden Planetarium.
I had gotten a job working at the hospital there at Tuskegee.
And I quit that when they wanted me to draw blood.
And I felt that that was...
I was inexperienced and actually...
I was comfortable with working in the laboratory and that they kept just sort of saying,
oh, you just go and do it.
And I just thought, no, you don't practice on people.
And they kept really pushing me.
And so the one point where I was, okay, I'm going to go and do this.
And it was a young woman who was in labor.
And then I felt no way in the world I am going to go and play...
You know, and practice with this poor woman who is in so much pain.
And so I just said, I quit.
And I assume that was a black hospital.
Yes, yes.
You're working in New York?
Did you consider trying to go to college in New York?
I didn't.
I didn't at that time because I had this scholarship.
I had gotten a scholarship by participating in a science fair.
It was a statewide science fair and that I won this...
It was Gorgas Scholarship sort of scholarship or something.
It was a black scholarship and it was full tuition and room and board
for four years to a black college in Alabama.
So it was a segregated prize.
You meant to buy off people who might be segregated in school?
But it was a prize nonetheless.
But it was a black prize.
I think that there was a white equivalent that went to then the university of Alabama
or all burn or something.
But then this was to the black schools.
What was your project?
My project was one where I did a demonstration of sound waves of showing how the frequency of sound waves could be graphically represented by...
I created this thing that would kind of like bobble and water, vibrate and water,
it had like a pool of water as a part of it.
And I made this little thing that would sort of touch down on it like a needle point but with something like a little cork or something.
And then if the frequency was higher, it had a different wavelength that from the base waves that...
And so I did all of the appropriate paper work to support this.
So it looked an interesting project.
And then you had to little re-estat thing where you could rev it up.
I mean this was a pre-radio shack.
It was called Tandy I think.
And there was the Tandy Corporation.
And they sold all of these kind of hobby things that went the gamut from the kind of stuff that you could find now in a radio shack.
To these little hobby kinds of kits where you could get a piece of little leather and stamp it with designs and burnish it.
Yeah.
So those that was my kind of place, I'm still gadget oriented.
And so it was my kind of place so I could go there and pick up enough things to sort of assemble this and put this project together.
I wondered if there was sort of influence by or shared interest like your dad's ability to take things apart and put them together.
Right, exactly. Well we had been very much encouraged along those that mode to develop those kinds of interest or to feel that if you had an interest like that, then you could...
You should just do it.
And the same was true of it ranged from architecture so that at one point he was going to expand the house.
And he asked that we would submit designs for the expansion.
So we all did and that we proposed that we should have this playroom and that we should have...
My room would be on one side, their room would be on the other side, the boys.
And that we would be separated by this larger playroom that would have an elevated platform for our electric trains.
And it went quite well. The one thing that he did that he shouldn't have done, he shouldn't have followed our advice about the skylights.
It would be great to have skylights in this playroom and the heat that came through those things in summer.
Uninsulated glass, I mean I didn't set the place on fire.
It was... Yeah.
So did the three of you develop it together?
We were working separately and then we had each our separate designs and then after he sort of picked aspects from each design and everything that then we became more of a team and worked together.
That was an interesting thing.
It was.
And I had the vision that it would have the room for the trains would have the scenery all around the walls and that it would have the sky.
So I was like my little cysteine chapel bit to paint all of the stars and clouds and things.
And then the trees along the walls and everything.
So it was quite an undertaking.
Sounds like it. I don't know many parents do have the kids in here like this space for that.
Yeah. Or it's like, you know, fine, go draw on the walls.
Well, that's not all that.
And then he would... Then I would move from that to wanting canvas.
And so he would buy me canvas and paints.
So I started doing oil paintings and I would draw.
And there was one time that he... I wanted a friend of mine had a monopoly game.
And oh, I just thought it was so much fun and I wanted a monopoly set.
And he refused to buy me one. He said, absolutely not.
And so once, when we came, I borrowed my friend's monopoly set and I made a copy to it at Cardboard and I copied her.
I wish that I had it now because it would be folk art now.
But I copied her monopoly set down to making my box, making the box to put the board in.
And the only thing that I didn't make original, as original things, were the little pieces.
I made the little houses. But then there were the little tokens that you could have as a...
Would they represent it? You write exactly.
And I found... I've forgotten where I got those, but I got some little toys or something to serve for those.
Did you like playing monopoly as well on your board or your stuff?
I did. Very much so with my own money that I had made my...
But I took the time to do the whole thing.
So you had a lot of creativity and independence in your childhood?
So, and that later, I mean, that became a real asset. Those were things that became real strengths for me later.
So going back to Tuskegee and now having to sort of make a living for myself, one point I had worked in the hospital.
And then another point I worked for this photo studio.
And I went there, I was doing these colored tents.
There was a point. You were... instead of color photographs, they were black and white photos.
And then you then applied, you know, like little rosiness to the cheeks, lipstick.
And you touched the black and white photos.
Almost like a photoshop.
Yeah, it was. It really was.
And so I then was doing that for this photographer.
And that later, I mean, years later, after I had long, after I had left Tuskegee,
I discovered that that was like a famous photography studio.
This was one of these, you know, like James Vandersie.
This guy, I think, is Polk, was another one of these, you know, great photographers and collect, you know,
someone who documented the African American community in these striking ways.
So that was yet another place that I had worked.
But through this work, sometimes I ended up meeting people who were beyond just the classroom.
So I didn't have an experience of Tuskegee with just, I'm getting up and I'm going to class
and I'll be back in my dorm room.
But I ended up then meeting people that took me beyond that.
And I was put into an honors program where I didn't have to go to conventional classes
that I had had one, like I took calculus with just meeting with the professor.
And I was allowed to pick classes that were not unlimited to the undergraduate program.
So I had friends, I took classes in the School of Veterinary Medicine.
You know, because like I said, I really enjoyed biology and everything.
And so I took a course in animal parasitology, I remember.
Is that parasit?
Yeah, it's disgusting.
And then it was.
You know, how many worms can inhabit the stomach of a...
But so I took some of those courses and I took another one on.
It was poisonous plants.
But through the School of Veterinary Medicine, I was taking these sort of more advanced classes.
And that then led me towards to a mingle with a group of people who were in some cases actual professors as opposed to students.
So through them, I met people who...
There was a woman, Dr. Doris Mitchell, who was a resident of Tuskegee,
and who came from a...
I think her family... I think her father may have been a doctor.
She herself was a veterinarian and that she and Odetta were friends.
And that she...
And that she had a... a damellor.
I had never... she had a little sports card that she had had imported from Germany.
She had a damellorke that she sort of toulal around in...
In Macon County.
And this house that was just incredible.
So I was being exposed to this people who...
And it was both intellectual exposure, just in cultural, but also then it meant that you were talking of, you know, much more seriously about ideas.
And that of course, ideas at that time meant that you were talking about race and racism as well.
And the problems of, you know, segregation and the lack of opportunity for people of color.
So what are some of the civil rights things that you're doing while you're at Tuskegee?
While you're also working in expanding your network?
So I started working on going out into the rural Macon County with registering people to vote.
And I don't remember whether that was at the behest of, you know, the Go-Millian group or some...
I don't know quite how that started, but that was one of the things that I started doing.
And then I met Gwen M. Patton and Gwen M. Patton.
George was a chemistry.
He was a graduate student in chemistry, I believe, at Tuskegee at the time.
And so I met these other students who had similar interest and I began to work with them.
And...
Were the students of Tuskegee focused entirely on civil rights in the community or the viewing of campus issues?
Both. Both.
Yeah.
What was the group like to you remember about the group?
We spent a lot of...
We were at first, I think we were a very cohesive, productive group.
And then we later became divided.
And the division came not out of really an intellectual or strategic divide.
It became much more the question.
That it became a wiki Willie "Mukasa" Ricks came to Tuskegee as a representative of SNCC.
And that it became much more a question of, wait, this is our group, don't you tell us what to do?
And that it was...
That was became the kind of dividing line.
And because we were now beginning to have demonstrations and participate, I can't recall what some of the...
What the key issues were then.
But I know we were doing some...
We were...
The issues were not on campus.
We were doing work like the work was much more desegregating Macon County in the sort of downtown Tuskegee.
And issues then about voting rights there.
And that had sort of brought us to the attention of SNCC.
And so people like Willie "Mukasa" Ricks and Willie "Mukasa" Ricks,
Willie "Mukasa" Ricks, people started coming through, SNCC people started coming through.
And that that then led to this kind of tension with our group of feeling that, well,
SNCC can do whatever it wants over there, but that we will be doing these things here.
This is our group and this is what we will be doing.
And there was a point at which I felt that it was...
That that was counterproductive.
And that what we were talking about was a bit too parochial too.
And that I started leaning towards SNCC because I felt that they were engaging the larger issues.
That it was that they had...
The dialogue was much more about what was happening in the country as a whole.
And it was a strategy than they were much more strategic in thinking that, well, if we can...
This is a black belt county.
If we can do this with these black belt counties plural,
that then we might be able to create some change rather than let's march through downtown Tuskegee.
Do you think your broader exposure may be receptive to SNCC's analysis or to choosing the broader analysis over the more focused?
I'm not sure because with some of this was the exposure beforehand.
And it says, I think I was predisposed towards civil rights activity from having grown up in Birmingham,
having participated in the demonstrations when I was in high school,
Birmingham then being the place where the church had been bombed.
I guess you would have been a little freshman.
Yeah, I was in college.
And that my brother, though, knew the family that one of the girls, you know, from one of the girls.
So it was...
So I think I felt this connection to those things.
And I also used to read a lot.
And some of the readings, also, and as I had grown up in this circumstance that was very much a union town too,
with people who were coal miners and steel workers and talked about John L. Lewis and so on the importance of unions.
I think I had that kind of sense of that if we are organized, that organization and being organized,
you can have a voice that you won't be alone and that your voice can make a difference.
So that was something that I think had been there as a small seat that was now beginning to grow.
And that when by the time I was in Tuskegee again for at 64, then right after I had come back from New York,
they were asking for volunteers.
They wanted more student volunteers to go to Mississippi to work on the November elections.
And this was the November 64 elections.
They were trying to get people to come to Jackson, Mississippi and to other parts to help register people.
And I had just missed freedom summer.
And so I said yes.
And for me, that was one of the times in my life that I felt...
I felt that I was making a conscious decision about doing something and I was doing it alone and that was fine with me.
It wasn't like, oh, you're my best friend, will you go with me? We could go.
It was that no, this is something that I feel is important to do and that I will go.
And I didn't need other people's approval, validation. I didn't need parental validation approval.
I could say yes, I will go and I went.
It was an experience.
It was... I went and I stayed.
I want to think that I stayed at the place where with you Vester Simpson, I think that she...
But I went there and that, you know, they had us come to a meeting and after we got off the bus and they said,
here's where you'll stay and I said, fine. And then they asked, I said, we're going to meet, so we'll be gathering here.
And then they told us that what they wanted us to do was to go do this door to door canvassing in this particular part of Jackson.
And that's what I did.
I felt, you know, I was really comfortable with that.
The part that was uncomfortable for me oddly enough was the social side of it.
Because I was shy, introvert.
And so when it... I find when I'm working, but then when people are socializing,
and that I wasn't accustomed to the sort of... I remember saying to someone that your husband says that's...
And she just laughed, this girl just laughed, because, you know, I mean, I had...
I made the automatic assumptions as they were kissing on each other and everything.
But she just thought that was so funny, you know, that I would assume that...
And I realized it.
And that it's something where this was a time where people were a lot more liberal with...
And so that's where I was not there with them on the social side of these things.
But these New York parties were... they were much more mad men style.
I mean, they were tame by comparison to...
So going to Mississippi for voter registration was a whole difference?
Yes. So it was an eye-opening experience in that way.
But that I was very comfortable with the work side of it.
But it was like, oh, I don't know. People were, you know...
So, you know, with one of the guys like, you know, flirting with me or something that was a little off-putting and a little scary to me.
But because I was, you know, sort of so green and everything.
I think he was a little bit... not ready for that.
And so that was... so that's the November 64 election.
It's after Freedom Summer, but it's before the voting rights act.
So you still have trouble getting people to be successful at registering to vote?
Do you have a sense of whether they're accomplishing this?
I didn't. Because I just felt that I was like a little soldier in the...
In the big unit?
In the bigger unit. And so I didn't... I didn't feel that I was privy to nor understood the larger strategy and how successful people were at that.
But that I just felt that then I could... this was something that I could do. I could talk to people.
And that I felt very good about it. I was really proud of myself for having gone.
Because people were talking about, oh my God, Mississippi. Oh, it's too dangerous.
And I would never go to Mississippi. And that I just...
It's like Mississippi, Alabama.
It's right...
You say people in Mississippi say that about Alabama.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
You know, here I am in Tuskegee. I'm in the middle of Alabama.
And that I'm going to think that it's more dangerous to go across the border to...
You know, the state line to Mississippi.
And of course, this was after Freedom Summer and after Goodman, Schwurney and Cheney.
So it was...
Does that exacerbate the concern?
That very definitely meant for it.
So, but I didn't feel that that made it a given that something would happen to me
or that my life was in mortal danger or anything.
So, but I could understand how people from the north or, you know,
some were a student from Chicago or something might be quite reluctant to do so.
Were you still in school for the Selma to Montgomery?
I was.
I mean, I guess I just made a big leap from...
Well, I guess it's November 64. That starts...
That'll recognize and start it in early 65.
So that would have been the same school year then.
And I was in school and that I left...
I'll have to look and see when I left school.
I worked with SNCC.
I started working very definitely with SNCC.
I've moved away from the campus group.
I still worked with them occasionally, but I moved much further away from the campus group
and started working with SNCC.
And at first in Wilcox County, AL, and this was down around G's bin,
and then I worked.
And so at that point, there was a point at which I left school,
and I want to think that I left school in probably in the spring of 1966.
I know I was still in school when my classmate, Samuel Younge Jr, was killed.
And Sammy was a part of the student group there.
And we as a student group were participating in the Selma to Montgomery activities.
From Tuskegee, I know that we were coming from Tuskegee.
I was not yet working and living in Lowndes County, AL.
Later, I actually worked and lived in the Freedom House in Lowns, but that was later.
But at this point, I was still in Tuskegee, and Gwen M. Patton, Gwen M. Patton, Samuel Younge Jr,
George Paris, Wendy Paris, that a group of us were working, CJ Jones.
It was a whole group of us who were Tuskegee students, and that we would go to work in Wistnik in Lowndes County, AL.
And go over to Selma, and that's when I met Phyllis Cunningham, who was there with the medical group.
So when you initially are working with SNCC, you're still in classes, and you're going back and forth with Tuskegee to Selma to Wilcox to announce...
Right, right. And at a certain point, that, yeah.
And at a certain point, that became unrealistic and untenable, and that I decided that I would leave school.
I felt that I had to make a decision.
Was there a very difficult decision for me because I felt that I had worked out one way of having my college education paid for.
And...
And now, I was, if I said goodbye to that, and worked full time in SNCC, that I had no means of support.
What would you do to return to college?
What would I do to return to college? What would I do even for just to...
To live?
To live, you know, that when students were going to go home for a summer or something at the end of a school year, where would I be going?
Yeah.
So you didn't think you could or would want to go home to your college?
I didn't want to.
I could, but I wouldn't want to.
You could sort of pass that over living at home.
Yes. And because my father...
He was an eccentric tinkerer, and that as the years were going by, he was becoming even more so.
And sadly, I think he was beginning to show some signs of a dementia, you know, but...
But that it's... So it was not something that I was. I did not...
And for me, I didn't want to return to Fairfield to live.
That was... To me, something that I just knew that I would never want to live there in my life, you know.
Can you articulate why it was that you felt you had to make the choice or that you wanted to make the choice to work full-time in the movement despite what it would mean in terms of your future?
I felt that I was becoming...
My time was to divide it between the two.
I was torn between these activities.
That on one hand, you know, I had a professor who was then sort of saying, don't forget, we're to meet at a certain point.
And as I said, they had been quite liberal with me in terms of the approach that was being taken about my classes and everything.
It wasn't as though I had to show up to 20 classes or anything.
But still, I did need to write papers and to do certain things in order to succeed academically.
And at the same time, though, then there was the... We need to have a meeting. This is taking place.
We need, you know, to go and talk to Canvas this area to get the people to come to this meeting.
So, where do you stand? What do you do?
And that's when I thought long and hard about it.
And I became even... It was a hard decision.
I became, I remember becoming quite depressed at one point about, you know, what do I do?
And I didn't have anybody that I really could talk to about this.
That my brother, who was at Tuskegee, he and I are very close, but that he was sort of a good guy, more sort of social party animal.
He had a sports car and he was supportive of the movement.
But he had definitely created a good work like balance for you.
We should involve parties and girls and things in sports cars.
So, I just felt that I had to just think this through and make this decision.
And that's when I decided that I would work, I would leave school and work with SNCC.
And then I convinced myself that I could return.
That I would be able to at some point, that if later, then I wanted to go and study medicine, I would be able to do so.
But for now...
Did you know that SNCC had, or at least was trying to have the work study program?
In Mississippi, some of the SNCC folks would work the while and go back to school for a while.
No, I didn't. Yeah, no, I didn't.
I think it was when I held a baker.
Uh-huh.
That's amazing. Right, exactly.
The student group, which was Gwen Pat and Gwen M. Patton and a number of us,
were working both on the campus.
But the real...
Our student group met on campus, but the real focus of our work was the Macon County area downtown Tuskegee,
such as that is, this little...
And that then we also, though, started working on with SNCC,
and the other civil rights group on the Selma de Montgomery, Marge.
And that was when we were...
We students became really part of a group that was going to not start so much in Selma, but go and demonstrate in Montgomery.
Do you know what the thinking was behind going to Montgomery rather than Selma?
I don't recall. Yeah.
When...
I guess I'm just going to head a little bit here about the work that you were doing with Tuskegee students in the county or in the community.
When you start working more with SNCC, not so much in Montgomery, but in the rural counties,
does that moralist the same kind of workers or distinction, the difference in that work?
For me, the...
It was the distinction was that it was strategically more around the vote and around registering African Americans to vote,
and trying to gain pluralities of voters in those black belt counties.
And so Macon Wilcox, Lowns, those counties in Alabama had significant black populations,
and that we were then trying to get as many registered voters in each of them.
At that point, were you thinking about the moral of independent politics,
or were you thinking more directly just in terms of the vote and not necessarily what happened next?
Or thinking more of the...
We were thinking that if we could register people, and if you could get a plurality in that particular county,
that you could in effect have black people in charge of the county government,
and that you could change the dynamic of life in the county by having then the sort of authority of county government.
Were you aware of...
I mean, I know you said you followed Freedom Summer.
Did you have an understanding of how Smith thought the challenge had gone in Atlantic City?
I mean, I know the people who went through that many of them were disappointed by that.
Very much so, yes.
And also learning from it.
So was that something that was communicated to you or that you were aware of?
I was aware of it in a general way.
It wasn't as though people didn't mull over it, talk about it, you know, add in for an item.
But there was the notion that that was an approach that had worked only up to a certain point.
And that had not...
It had failed in one sense, but that now what we could do is begin to deal with these black belt counties
and particularly lounds, and that if we could then gain and really transform the government of one of these counties,
that that would be a path to a different kind of victory and a different kind of politics.
I don't know if you would remember or if you would have been aware of this.
It's been a long time, so I don't know those specifics.
But I had a sense that although Mr. Gimillian was a...
or Dr. Gimillian was a path-breaker in many ways pursuing the franchise and challenging the Jerry Mandry,
that once the Voting Rights Act passed or once he won some of those court cases,
that some people thought he was a little conservative in applying that,
that he wanted to be careful not to threaten whites too much with this black majority.
You remember that?
No, I don't remember that.
And so I think that there would have been a difference between the making dynamic with that and the lounds dynamic.
So I wondered if you were passing through that.
Yeah, and it's interesting because it's something where now in hindsight, you know, so many years later,
I still... I'd have to go... I'm curious about what we were attempting to do as a whole in Wilcox County, AL, for example,
and why we felt that, oh, let's not put too much effort there.
Why lounds got the bulk of the attention?
I feel that I understand why lounds got the bulk of the attention.
But we had enough people and enough interest to have maintained activity in Wilcox as well.
But I feel that there was somehow strategically that we didn't quite...
that we... there was felt that it wasn't necessary or that it wasn't...
it wasn't possible to have the same kind of win.
And Wilcox was an interesting place in it of itself.
It had a completely different dynamic there because of the kind of isolation of G's been.
Okay.
Was it... I mean, my sense is it had the same kind of black majority...
It had the black supermajority, but they had the whites had cut the bridge.
So the G's been was this little world unto itself.
And it was so difficult for them to connect...
To even go... right, exactly.
Were there any sizable towns in Wilcox or green?
There are, but I can't even remember the names of them.
And particularly in Wilcox, we didn't go to the principal town because that was the one that was sort of cut off in a sense.
So is G's been a town? I always think of it more as just rural.
It's more rural, but it is... it's an enclave.
I mean, it's... now we would... something having that same dynamic we call a subdivision.
But in those days, it was... and you probably know all of the history of it and how...
Coming out of the New Deal, it was one of those kind of...
Farm security?
Yeah, and it had the...
Well, where they had also a community center.
And then people had these houses all sort of... it was a planned community in that way.
Was it funded through the Farm Security Administration?
I don't know.
Farmers are by and by and...
And all of the people were named Pettway.
Black and white?
All the blacks.
They came from the Pettway plantation and they were all named Pettway.
So everybody was a Pettway.
But so it was an unusual place and it culturally and it...
and it kind of isolated place.
But going back to GoMillion,
I remember him as being one of the players and a force there,
but I don't remember doing things actively in Macon.
There's a...
I think that you've seen it.
It's a book about the community in school.
I want to continue with my own book before I don't want to forget my own book.
I want to forget Montgomery.
So can you talk about what's the Montgomery...
You said that Tuskegee students were going to Montgomery during the Montgomery
to...
Selma to Montgomery in the large and doing demonstrations there.
Can you describe your involvement in that and what it was like?
I recall there...
and now Jim James Forman, in addition to other SNCC people,
Jim James Forman was also a presence at Tuskegee.
And Jim and some other SNCC workers,
then were asking that we would then go to Montgomery.
And I recall that we then had picket signs.
I don't remember what the signs said,
but that we then went to March in front of the state capital in Montgomery.
And this is...
This is the...
What used to be the White House of the Confederacy,
where Jeff Davis has a star or something.
And so we were going to demonstrate there.
And that students would go and would march there and then go back to campus.
And we then went...
And the day that we went, there was a counter-demonstration.
There were...
I think there were maybe about...
I want to think maybe about 40...
40, 50 of us.
And that we were marching in this oval loop there in front of the state capital.
The capital itself behind us, there was a...
state troopers with their Billy Clubs,
and they would slap them against their thighs for dramatic effect.
Now, and so they were standing there in a big line.
So you knew that you couldn't go further that way.
And there was a point at which the...
It was the clan or a group.
The people said it was the clan, but they were not robed.
But they were these men and women, white men and women,
that then in these cars that came up.
And we're coming...
You could see them come up the street there.
And they were coming up.
And you know, a few cars came up,
of course, you had the usual nigger and a few other things.
And there was like a big parade though of them coming.
And the troopers started saying that clan was coming
and that they were talking among each other.
And that we, meanwhile, are still marching like this.
And then there was another...
At one point at which one of the officers said,
you know, arrest them all.
And it was almost on one hand.
And we had all...
We had been instructed.
We had all gone through the training where if you're being arrested,
you go limp and you're sort of carried and thrown into the paddy wagon
or the van or whatever.
And so we were arrested.
And that's what we went through our usual going limp.
And we're taken away.
And we were arrested just before that group came fully up the hill.
So it was on one hand a sense of relief about because you didn't quite know
if you're between...
The highway patrol and the clans.
Right. And the highway patrol with their billy clubs.
And then if you're with this sort of vigilante kind of group there,
it doesn't seem like a safe place to be.
No, not exactly.
And that it wasn't as though...
And we, I think, were thinking of it.
I know I later talked with one of my classmates who was there.
And that we were thinking that there was no place for us to go.
That if they had not arrested us,
then we would probably have sat down there.
And just...
Right.
So what happened when you were arrested?
So we were arrested and we were taken to this place, to this jail.
I think a Montgomery County jail.
And we were...
I think I was there for about like five days.
Yeah.
What was it like to be there?
It was...
On one hand, it was something where...
I wasn't afraid... I was not afraid at all.
And I wasn't afraid because there were so many of us.
You know, because we were together and we were singing freedom songs.
So the camaraderie and everything at the beginning was very good.
As time went on, it became harder.
And it became harder because of the conditions there.
You know, the bathrooms were overflowing.
So it was absolutely smelly, filthy, hard.
The food was, you know, just terrible and edible practically.
So, you know, somebody sort of said, let's go on a hunger strike and you felt that's easy enough to do.
Because the food was so absolutely so awful.
But I wasn't...
At any point, fearful.
I wasn't fearful for my life.
And that more people were being arrested, too.
And so the numbers were growing and it was a more diverse group that was being arrested.
There were some whites from New York and other places who now were, you know, being brought in.
And so you were meeting these people.
So it was like a giant gathering of people, of women.
And there were some local women who were a little befuddled.
You know, the people who had been arrested for other things.
I never asked or found out what they were had been arrested for.
But they were a little, they found us curiosities.
And we'd all, you know, sort of mingle and talk.
And what, how did you get out?
Did somebody bail you out?
Someone bailed us out.
Yeah.
You want to keep doing it longer?
Someone bailed us out.
Did you have to go back and go to court?
We did not.
That I think that I want to think that William Conzler had arranged for us to be released.
And I want to think that they filed some things where later all of the charges were dismissed.
And I think we were arrested.
I think the charge was that we were arrested for resisting arrest.
That's always a curious one.
Exactly.
But you were resisting arrest with no charge.
Right, exactly.
So I think that it wasn't probably too challenging to get it tossed out once.
Yeah.
But I think that Conzler, because I think Conzler played a role then in our being released.
I know that a lot of people say that he played an important role in coming up with some of the more creative strategies of forcing the issue.
And like that.
And on a subsequent arrest in Atlanta with Karen Edmonds Spellman, Fay Bellamy Powell, and Ruby Doris Smith Robinson,
one during the holiday season in December in Atlanta, when I was working in the Atlanta office, we were arrested.
And then I think Howard Moore Jr, then he was the person who...
I knew that he did a lot of movement.
So you Ruby Darius, Karen Edmonds Spellman, and Fay Bellamy Powell, what were you all arrested for?
We had been working at the SNCC office all day and it was in the midst of the Christmas holidays.
And we'd been working and we'd close the office.
The office was now closed and we thought, oh, you know, let's do something that would just be relaxing and fun.
And you said, oh, let's get arrested.
And we thought, no, let's go to Auburn Avenue.
Let's go down to the main black street at that time in Atlanta, Auburn Avenue.
And here's some music and have dinner and here's some music.
And we were walking there and we had aphoros.
So we were rather distinctive, identifiable.
And so we were walking along and that Fay was very tall and gazelle-like.
It was very striking and so the group of us all walking, just us women walking down.
And these black policemen then slowed down to a crawl and then they are driving alongside us.
I mean, we're walking and they now are driving along at the same pace that we're walking.
And Fay then finally says, and what are you looking at?
And what do you want? And that she used an expletive along with that.
And they pulled over and arrested us.
So here we were. And you know, of course, and we were saying, what, how can we be, what have we done?
And how did you feel about that?
Well, it became yet another interesting evening.
But it was, it was, what was it that one of the later we found that the, I think two of the policemen were like Vietnam vets.
Yeah, yeah.
And but it was this whole thing of what, what is this about and why?
And it was this kind of, you felt that you were being harassed because we were obviously movement people, you know, made it.
And that was our hair was the giveaway.
And that the, why the, that the police would then just feel that, oh no, somehow they were going to show us who was the authority here.
What about the fact that they're black officers?
Oh, that's what I feel that it was more about. I feel that it was about them sort of feeling that, oh no, we'll show you.
So who's the authority here?
It's a way that they can exercise their authority.
Right, exactly.
Probably not doing that in the white community.
Right.
I do think, I mean, I think you probably experienced this, but it seems like black police were explicitly intended to control the black community when they were first running.
Well, I think that there was a kind of, and in different places, I think black police have played, you know, different roles, varying roles.
But I think in this particular circumstance, that this was a time when I believe that they felt that civil rights and that the movement, and, you know, this is like black power and all of those kind of frightening things for them that question, that challenge their authority.
And lead to, you know, sort of could lead to riots and all kinds of problems.
And so, and I think that they just felt that, oh, this is an easy chance to just show these people in the civil rights movement, you know.
So you're very present as a threat?
Yeah.
So is this, you said it's Christmas, it's the era of black powers, it's probably like December 66 to December 67?
I think it's probably like 67.
I'll have to try to find Karen, Karen, you know, I can get some validation for some of these things from her, sadly, the numbers of people who are still alive and can do that.
Yeah.
Have Dwindle.
So can you tell me tell us what it was like to be organizing the Lounge County?
Living in Lounge County?
I was living in Lounge County and I had, at first I had been living in Wilcox County, AL and would come over for meetings with Stokely, Carmichael, Ralph Featherstone, Courtland Cox, Charlie Cobb, Ivanhoe.
We would meet there from time to time and they would be, some of them would be coming from Atlanta and we would all then have these meetings.
But then when I was asked to actually come and work in Lounge County, then I moved into the Freedom House.
So the building, they are photographs of the shack, you know, which had been, I think, belonged to the Jackson family.
So that shack of a house was our office by day but it was also then where we actually stayed.
And we had sleeping bags and so we'd sleep in our sleeping bags and the building was, you could see the stars by looking up and you could see the ground by looking down.
It's just like camping.
We had one of those little pot belly stoves that would stoves that you used that to keep warm and so those conversations around the fire mitt that you turned one way.
And after that part of your body started getting toasty, you then turned another way.
So these conversations had this sort of natural rhythm of movement to them.
But it was really interesting that I, that was a very special time for me.
I was, I was very pleased that the, that I was considered one of the, you know, key workers there and that it was not that I was being treated like, oh, you're a girl, you're a woman.
But it was that at the, in the evening when we get together and we'd be sitting around that, you know, the little stove or we'd be talking that we, we were talking about what had happened during the day in terms of our work in the county.
But it was a wonderful time where we were also talking broader strategies and about the world and we were, some of us were reading Frantz Fanon.
And, you know, reading his books and black skins, white masks and we would talk about what, what did, what does freedom mean?
You know, what does revolution mean? What does change mean? What does it mean to have power?
What's happening in the world and what is it that we would want for our people of Ralph Featherstone, for example, felt that economic empowerment was absolutely essential.
And he thought that we should eventually work on projects that would bring greater economic empowerment to people and that's something that he, before his death, you know, had worked on some projects that were around the economics.
He was a teacher too, right? Or he was in SNCC? Yes, yes.
What were some of the economic ideas that he had of projects he worked on?
Well, they, in some parts of Mississippi, they started doing catfish farming where, where you could, you know,
you know, a pair of people could then raise catfish and sell those commercially.
I mean, I heard of that in the Delta, but I didn't realize that SNCC was involved in that.
Well, SNCC, for say, wasn't, but...
But he was working independently?
Right. He later, you know, as time moved on, he began, yeah.
And that he then, for example, Ed Brown, was another person who was interested in the economic empowerment ideas.
And so he eventually became the head of that group, Mississippi Action for Community Education, in Mississippi.
And so Ed and Charles Bannerman and a few others then worked on setting up those kinds of activities.
They had one fine vines, I think it was called for. It was a blue jeans, where people were doing...
They were doing textile work and then also doing piece work for sewing jeans like garment work.
So that, they were doing those kinds of things. And I worked with them. I worked for...